hey my funny goofy hat don't i look like
hella from thor don't you sometimes just
want to club that kevin smith well how
about instead you joined that kevin
smith club oh my god we've been having
such a good time we have hours of audio
kids in the smodcast podcast archives
that you can stick into your ear holes
and listen to or do you want to look at
something are you one of them dirty
[ __ ] and then go to the smithstoneian
screening room where you can watch
hundreds of hours
of video of my entire career spanning
from the beginning up till now including
my daily morning show wake and bake man
will we just smoke weed hang out and i
tell you what i'm working on plus
there's exclusive events we've had
clerks 3 screenings for our club members
we've had smod castle exclusive shows
for our members back in jersey we do
events
all the time including movies pop-ups
and there's tons of merchandise of
course that that kevin smith club
members get exclusive access to before
anybody else there are so many ways into
that kevin smith club ladies and
gentlemen you don't have to come through
the front door you can come through the
back door we like it that way sign up as
a clerk where you get access to all the
audio that we got or join as a mall rep
that gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun employee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that kevin smith
club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that kevin smith waking bake
bowl ladies and gentlemen those are our
existing levels but what about the new
levels that's right for 2022 we've added
some levels including the fashionable
mail you get everything that the clerk
the mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bacon it goes
up on spodcast man very exclusive once a
year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rat be a fun employee be a yo-go's
or be a fashionable male be a ranger
danger or be a golden calf ladies and
gentlemen i'll be waking and baking for
you come join me at that kevin smith
club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings good evening kids it's a magic
manic monday and welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernard
hey
that's right it's me
goddamn mark bernardin because if you
can't get an angel you could still get a
mark and bernardin be the next best
thing the next best thing to an angel
bernardin be the next best thing
give me the guitar why didn't you come
in with yeah there you go bring it in
[ __ ] nice
how are you captain
i'm good man i'm good it's a friggin
monday and hollywood and
dreams are getting made and the diamonds
and the soldier your shoes it's all
it's all glory and wonder
very very true dreams are getting made
as are
nightmares
this is the q proskate
kevin smith looks like this
um comes in a box like this
from the folk from the folks at bandai
wow you're a bandai warrior now
look at how [ __ ] adorable that is
don't you want one kids this is our
sponsor tonight never mind the blue
chews and the other you know
the
the natives and whatnot tonight
it's this [ __ ] right here that
haunts your dreams don't you want this
right next to your
[ __ ] bedside table
don't you want to escape that faces you
could you could leave this at crime
scenes and really baffle [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
um
37.37
signed over at
jayansalambob.com that link probably
went up a second ago
get a look at that look how adorable it
is fat man beyond sponsored by
hugh paskett
hidden dancing you'll see him when we
come back and stuff but him he's having
a good time remember he's like hugo the
puppet and uncle floyd you could do [ __ ]
like that it's the things that get me
the hands i'm in love with you can put
it right on your desk so he can watch
you while you masturbate
or prevent you from masturbating if
you're one of those conservatives what
are you doing what is happening
so much about in the last few days the
cuposket ladies and gentlemen kevin
smith
by bandai
37.jsonbob.com go we'll wait
i mean in a world where like native and
and um and blue chew
continue to come back to us we must be
able to sell things right
well you just gave me some information
about another thing that we sold
and sold very well
that's right look at you you want a
humble brag let's do it so kids san
diego comic-con is is
coming so hard that uh it's pre-coming
as we speak so it happens like within a
month i believe
uh for
the san diego comic con this year
uh we are
taking over the
tin roof san diego
in is it the gas lamp district is indeed
and it's becoming a movies pop-up for
the whole
run so thursday friday saturday sunday
um thursday and friday reservations for
eating have
sold out so we're trying to wedge in
more we were not prepared for the
success that we're enjoying right now um
saturday and sunday there's still slots
open
and that's during the day and during the
day i'm going to be hanging out there
signing stuff
we're going to stream some shows me and
mark
uh but at night
it becomes movies after dark and we do
live shows the first show on thursday
night
is fat man beyond and if you wanted to
see me and mark do it you are s-o-l
you're gonna have to watch the live
stream like everyone else because it's
sold out
that's right man most popular show of
the lineup sold out like that thursday
night's been that's that preview night
where people are in town and all the
parties haven't begun yet so they're we
are the party we're the party we're the
[ __ ] party
so they're gonna come to movies after
dark they're going to watch us do fat
maybe they could eat [ __ ] drink while
it's going on oh it's gonna be good it's
just gonna be like being at the cantina
speaking of cantina where's banff man
bam bam jump in here real quick bamf
hey everybody it's banff man uh banff
man is heading out of here right after
this show kids it's not gonna be a long
show tonight
not it's not gonna be long like it
normally is long like mark's dick
tonight small and short and tight and
compact yet satisfying
kev's dick um
it is a show we're probably not gonna be
doing a lot of news stories it's mostly
to review
uh kenobi but we wanted to get a show in
under the wire
before banff man gets the [ __ ] out of
dodge tell them what you're doing banff
man
i am
taking my 18 month old daughter and my
wife back to the house she grew up in in
upstate new york uh
so we're
taking a plane from lax to vegas
changing planes taking a plane from
uh vegas to chicago a plane from chicago
to albany and then have a three-hour
drive
north
north
to
her house
at the canadian border
this is one of those times just one
where right about now you're like [ __ ]
it'd be awesome if i was ben affleck
because you were ben affleck
it's one flight in it yeah
you're pj in it right to that location
oh my god the amount of travel makes my
[ __ ] nuts hurt and it's not just like
you doing it solo it's not just you and
jenny doing it
it's you jenny and the baby
who now wants to walk everywhere i know
and after all this time
get up walk you're in a place where
you're like sit down don't move shut up
and
just in case anybody wants to rob me i
do have people staying and watching our
dogs so don't rob my house when i'm gone
excellent tip kids
you should get on the internet tell
people not to rob you before you leave
you all have something to sell on the
show i have the cuposket from bandai jc
has the idea of not robbing
them do you ever worry about that though
where you're like we're traveling
everywhere and our house is empty
oddly enough i
there's always someone here
so i don't travel i don't worry about
like what if like somebody burglarizes
the house i worry and said like what if
somebody's home invaded at the house um
but knock wood so far that's something
we having a crazy alarm system and [ __ ]
like that but you guys live out in like
the hinterlands you live in straw dog's
country yeah if i was you guys i'd be
[ __ ] scared being at the house
[ __ ] never mind being away from that
yeah like i lived where brad pitt drove
and once upon a time in hollywood to get
out to that movie ranch that's never
right
that's chatsworth and i live in a town
next to chatham
lots of space out there yeah i know
you're wrong they have to have walk
their sidewalks for horses in that town
that's kind of charming it's it doesn't
smell great but it's true
nature doesn't smell great
turns out no lilacs and horse asses do
not mix so wait jc when you leave when
in the morning in the morning yeah it's
7 a.m
so we're going to we're also giving you
an itinerary like don't rob my house by
the way i'm leaving it
when you're going to leave so they know
when you're gone
the point of all that wasn't to let you
know when jc is robbable but instead let
you know that we're doing the show
tonight because a lot of people were
like what's going on monday show what's
going on just like how this is you know
they announced for the january 6
hearings they got a surprise hearing
tomorrow
we've got a surprise show tonight did
you read that
no there's a surprise hearing tomorrow
yeah they they were like we got
something so [ __ ] big we have to have
a surprise hearing they weren't
scheduled to go for another week or so
so what could it be
pence
you know what
that's a different show altogether in
any event
um we're doing the show tonight so that
we can get win under the wire before jc
goes away for
uh ever no he's going away for a long
time and then you know i'm going to
colorado this weekend to denver for fan
expo denver
nice and the week after that is fan expo
chicago so we didn't know when we were
going to be able to get
together again
and so we said let's do it monday night
let's talk about kenobi because the
kenobi finale
was spoilers if you're like i wonder
what they thought
by now
like it was a full week later
if you're wondering what we thought
you've never seen this [ __ ] show
before but
you know it was a spellbinding finale so
we were like let's actually you know do
a
review show before jc goes off on
vacation so
here we are also
i over bought these and so
i
i really need to move a lot of the 37
bucks kids and then come sign look how
fun it is
all the action of kev smith barely moves
just stands there poses i like if we we
widen the camera just be nothing but
these things
i'm sitting on a mountain of [ __ ] like
that
gotta send a message
everything burns and you just watch this
[ __ ] go up and
actually my mother's favorite item we've
ever made she took two home with her so
nice you know she helped out be like my
mom go to
janesolidbob.com
get yourself too
cute yeah please get two and [ __ ]
that'll teach me
everyone's gonna want one of these you
know what everyone does want at our
website so
when uh the news happened on friday the
very sobering news that like
uh hey we're taking rights away in this
country
uh you know naturally one feels
frustrated and wants to help in a way
shape or form uh we had this pin at our
website that originally we did as a
limited edition it was only going to be
137 of them
and then it was so popular like oh we'll
just put it in production and this
before
word dropped you know that the
supreme court was
looking strongly at roe v wade and so as
of friday
i i put up like look we're gonna these
pins
every piece of profit that we make goes
right to
planned parenthood so we have had a run
on i think we sold 20 000 bucks worth of
pins in that first day amazing um yeah
people naturally have very strong
feelings about
watching the clock get rolled back and
whatnot so this ain't the show where we
talk about that however if you're
you know prone to
prone to this sentiment the very famous
dogma sentiment where jay and silent bob
said a woman's body is their own [ __ ]
business which has you know been in my
timeline for the last
a few weeks but definitely for the last
few days pretty hardcore so uh
there you go i'm sure we just lost the
audience but
yeah i think it's a smaller majority
minority than me
um
anywho
how have you been my friend uh you know
i've i've been good at least as good as
one can be on the
sort of doorstep of a crumbling republic
um
it's
a little difficult to just hop in there
and write some
fantasy go go fun [ __ ] on friday
um but you know what it goes well it
goes well my my wife and i are staring
down the barrel
of two months left with a boy at home
before he goes off to college um and
ironically these are the two months in
which we will see him the least
because he's got himself a summer child
like he's a lifeguard so he's out of the
house almost all the time and he's got a
girlfriend she's going to see her the
other hand so we're like do we do we get
to see you at all no all right that's
fine
go go leave your life buddy
see when we drop you off at school
so it's a lot of you know the the bitter
sweetness of that emotional cocktail
and the cats in the cradle and the
silver spoon
the blue blue and the man and the moon
yeah
yeah man it's uh they age out
they do
they do it's fine we're at a time though
enjoyed it so you still got the summer
night of the summer you know and and it
is as it's supposed to be
um so i'm not i'm not sad about it at
all like it's it's all good news but
it's still you're feeling all the feels
and that's just fine
[Laughter]
i think the audience would love it if
you broke down emotionally look if i cry
on the show people are like it's a
monday if you cry on the show people are
like
there it is wow there's comicbook.com
we'll have a headline that's that's
right there's the soft chewy center
inside that that hard nut [ __ ] exterior
that everyone's been looking at this
hard nut
um yes
i uh what did i just i watched like
oddly enough i
i haven't watched a ton other than the
things we're going to talk about of
course i have been watching a [ __ ] ton
of on youtube
of a tv show i didn't know exist i don't
think they make it anymore but it's
called airline
and it like it was on a e back in the
day and it just took place at southwest
and it's just
southwest employees dealing with [ __ ]
problem passengers and problems is it a
reality show or is it like wings it's
like reality show
but
like you know they have
their human interest stories like you
know these
this family's trying to get to this
competition or blah blah and so you see
the southwest
staff helping but the hands down the
best part of the show
is drunk people trying to get on an
airplane
and you know i've always had an issue
with drunk people in my life i'll take a
stoner every any day but you know drunks
are
you never would know which way it's
going to go and stuff so
watching
this show where you're watching from a
safe distance and not only safe distance
like i'm a passive viewer but i think
the show was made like over 10 years ago
um it's so wild like
i don't know why because i'm not into
hostility but like i could totally watch
like people
get mad about like not being allowed on
the plane it's it's very like i've taken
a lot from it where i'm like i you know
i've it's been years since i've ever
been like i can't believe this is an
outrage or something like that generally
i now travel with a feeling of like if i
miss the plane that's my own damn fault
and
you know [ __ ] apparently it wasn't
that important for me to get where i was
going and stuff like i'm ready to take
my licks
none of these people are dude and all of
them negotiate
like they're [ __ ] like negotiating
with sharon
you know to not take them across the
[ __ ] sticks i guess that's a pretty
bad analogy negotiations like they're
all negotiating against the reaper
like please just 10 more minutes oh my
god it's [ __ ] delicious so i have
been watching that but
based on the
you know the news on friday i have much
more enjoyed
spending my time in the 80s the thing
that i'm writing which i'm now like at
page 60 on
i don't know if that's halfway or maybe
i'm past halfway
um but that takes place in 1986.
so
i've been taking refuge in the past
in my script where you know you anybody
can get an abortion and it's not a big
deal you know what i'm saying i mean you
know a big deal in the way it was a big
deal in fast times ridgemont high you
know a choice a personal choice
sometimes a hard choice tough choice to
make um not like now where it's
federally against the law
so it's not it's just not federally
protected
yes it's the states can choose whether
or not they want to enforce or or
decline
thank you for the correction
um but yes i've been enjoying
spending time
in
1986 which
i always think like i have a really good
memory of the past but
you know now i'm like well i'm very far
removed i'm like 35 years removed 36
years removed from that period and stuff
so i've been doing a lot of deep diving
by listening to music of the error which
to be fair
that's really the only music i ever
listened to anyway
um but it's been bliss but you know the
danger is like not making
time too many time jokes you get away
with a couple right
but like
you know you can't be like let's all get
abortions before it becomes a legal one
like obviously people will be like gee
when'd you write this
right but there's definitely some
time you know [ __ ] references in in
there um
not just morris day and the oh well
there's naturally that it's set in 1986
forever oh the era of purple rain oh did
he have ddo yes but there's uh
yeah man it's it's been a wild ride
and i'm kind of
i don't you know
it's it doesn't have a plot it just
meanders it reminds me of some [ __ ] that
like i used to write
before i got
you know formalized be like hey there's
three acts and blah blah blah just it
reminds me more of
you know
for lack of a better description clerks
has very little structure to it it just
kind of
starts and then stops and this kind of
does the same thing there's no big
thrust there's no big this is the plot
it's just really like a day in the life
a snapshot kind of thing
um and so in
writing that i was like let me go
check out some what they call
coming of age movies
um and i was gonna go watch some from
the 80s and stuff
uh but then i was like you know there's
this one like
that i've never i've been meaning to
watch i i in my head i was like i've
been even watched for like the last few
years
like it's a recent movie it's not it's
very old it's 10 years old almost 10
years old nine years old at this point
this movie the way way back
did you ever see it
that's affleck right
no
he's the way back interesting ah okay
how many ways 2013
and it's called the way way back steve
carell is in it
um
sam rockwell also janey
uh maya rudolph it's got killer cast
but um it's set at like a water park
like over the course of a summer
um really good flick and when i was
watching it i was like wow man i can't
believe i finally saw it and i thought
it was only a year too old but it's
almost [ __ ] 10 years
um
that was a nice thing to sink into other
than that though i've been pretty much
sinking into my
my own thing do you find when you're
writing that you're like i give a [ __ ]
about watching a thing
um i i tend to watch
things that are
diametrically opposed to the stuff that
i'm writing
you know so if like i'm if i'm writing a
drama drama then i'll watch just to
watch things like sitcoms and like light
stuff and give me like a half an hour
bite of a thing
um
not that i'm a big like half hour comedy
guy so it's hard to go the other way but
i try to not dip in the same pool that
i'm swimming in if you know what i mean
um i will say though that if you if you
want more airline if you want that that
feel
and you want a little bit more
contemporary just look up just random
youtube videos of people getting thrown
off planes for not wearing masks it led
to that
it led to that i've fallen down the
rabbit hole well obviously the
algorithm's like so you like airline
disasters on the ground yeah you know
and so it's been
feeding me really obnoxious people on
airplanes and at first jennifer my wife
was like don't watch this [ __ ] but it is
captivated man
like you know this is never mind like
you know they're always like reality tv
and [ __ ] like the real housewives oh
[ __ ] you want reality it's so cheap just
send somebody to an airport with a
[ __ ] iphone
and just let them shoot people melting
down it's nuts the other thing i've been
watching on youtube which is nuts is
this thing called code blue cam
from lacrosse wisconsin
it's like basically the
police camera on the on the chest is
this is this scan bc but already
video i mean but it's it's kind of drunk
bc once again
like the ones because there are some
serious videos where it's like well i'm
not interested in that but the videos
where it's just like
you know code blue cam police confront
really drunk 18 year old i'm like
especially when it's like 25 minutes
long i'm like that's a long
confrontation man
it's crazy dude like it's crazy
what drunk people will say like
they're just in a different world all
together
you know
like and and
this show like
makes me go like is anybody afraid of
the police because when they're drunk
it's just a non-stop verbal tie ready to
[ __ ] you like
be terrified get like beat down and
stuff is nuts but i guess the point is
they got cameras on them right right
theoretically tough to be
yeah
i don't know how
you could deal with that much in your
face hostility like what a thankless
position it's just constant cleanup
nobody's ever like
uh hey we found a you know [ __ ] a
bunch of joy and we just wanted to share
it with you officers
it always comes down to like something
bad has happened you [ __ ] go deal
with it
um it's it's been an interesting
[ __ ] watch man i'll tell you one
thing right now
i ain't ever getting drunk for the rest
of my life
it ain't worth it i can get high and
know that i'm constantly in control
but like being drunk like it seems like
i i mean people for those that don't
know i just don't drink i've never
really liked the taste of it so not not
that i'm like i i shame on people that
drink obviously i'm [ __ ] i'm vibed
differently but i don't like the taste
of booze so it always baffles me how
people can get to the point where
they've had so much booze that they're
like that they're completely out of
control of their faculties and in that
airline show and in that code blue cam
it's a never-ending series of people who
are just
so off the charts
drunk
like i never want to be i don't even
want to take that chance ever again i
don't think i'm such a lightweight man
you know like half of bartles and james
and i'd be like whoo
so
first you'd have to find one and then
you'd be i mean so i should stop chasing
the bud light seltzer sponsorship for
the show is what you're saying
probably man i mean i'm a little soft
for that
this is terrible that's it's like
watching a horror movie like it's so
preventative like you know out of horror
movies in the 80s they were like these
kids are [ __ ] and now they're getting
punished by dying and now they'll never
[ __ ] again god damn it
that's what watching airline is like for
me where i'm like
that's terrifying i'll never touch a
drink again especially touch a drink and
go near an airport holy [ __ ]
uh
yeah yeah yeah anyway
[Music]
we're sitting here going like reviewing
a you know [ __ ]
10 year old i will say though i did i
did dive deep have you ever seen hot
ones
the tv show where to eat the very hot
food
yes
i've been i've been i've been going hard
on the youtube version
and
there there is just
something
perfect about the the entire
the idea of the show which is it's a
talk show like you've got a host and
you've got a guest the guest is there
promoting their whatever the first one
that i saw was tom holland who was on
there promoting spider-man um no way
home
and uh you know tom
walks up you know sprightly energetic
time he sits down it's like alright
we're gonna eat these wings i'm gonna
ask you some questions and the questions
are all legitimately great like the dude
it's gonna be sean something i can't
remember his last name but um he does
fantastic research um he's incredibly
personable
and
it's that the show changes
as people begin to be assaulted by their
taste buds
by the heat of the food that they're
eating
and so just watching watching the the
the the predetermined image that you
have as an actor like if you're idris
elba you're a [ __ ] tough guy and then
you're doing your thing you're just
talking about yourself but you're having
your [ __ ] wings it's all [ __ ]
great but then you eat the wing that's
too hot and then you start to cry and
then you start to curse people and then
you start to curse the host and then you
start to curse everybody it's like who's
that whose [ __ ] idea was this i'm
gonna punch you in the face like
literally all decorum falls away
as your soul is is shred bare in front
of a camera and there is something as a
person who's watched lots of interviews
just done interviews or xenoblade
interviews watching the pretense of
press
fall away and like that's that person
right there in front of you who can't
keep his [ __ ] together enough to lie to
you like a celebrity does
there's something so lovely about it and
so i i did a deep [ __ ] dive like a
month ago and have not come up for air
i think i could do it i wanted to be on
that show at one point but like
i'm i'm not good with hot
sauce at all
and also you're already honest it was
like yeah that's true
um but in retrospect it was like i don't
even know if i can handle
like [ __ ]
that much hot sauce like my shit's
pretty mild so i don't even know if
they'd be like this [ __ ] is the middle
scoville [ __ ] raider
yeah i guess we should i know we're
reviewing hey kids [ __ ] uh guess what
we discovered some [ __ ] airline on a e
and hot ones on youtube that's what you
come to fat man beyond for get skinny
fingers on the [ __ ] pulse
and to pick up a cue posca 37
uh let's talk about kenobi shall we
let's do it ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna spoil
uh the whole damn series of obi-wan
kenobi that just played on disney plus
uh for the record since everybody's like
who won't you suck his lightsaber again
uh you're paid to do this
i i get no [ __ ] money uh to do this
at least not from the star wars people
the only money i get from doing this
is right here kids
37
gets you one of the look at this [ __ ]
man you can play
you can [ __ ] make your own youtube
videos and [ __ ]
in any event point being when we talk
about these shows we talk about them
because like
we talk about just because we like them
um although i will say one more time for
the record
because i just saw all these amazing
pictures
from the thor
loving thunder premiere
literally
a seven minute walk
from my house
and i'm like
what what are we doing wrong man i don't
know like not only do we not get paid to
talk about this stuff yeah we don't even
write us as [ __ ] we don't get screeners
of any
nothing man oh my god you're so right we
don't even get like you know i see like
[ __ ] uh other websites
have like they get involved in the
junket
where all of a sudden they're [ __ ]
zooming with major celebrities and i'm
like
what are we doing wrong and then i
realized
we're just not spiffy enough martin
if we if we look at this clean
this is who they want to talk to not
this
this ain't nobody dope is me i'm just so
fresh so clean
it's crazy though man i honestly like
sometimes i wonder if somebody there is
just like no [ __ ] those guys
yeah but like somebody everywhere is
like [ __ ] those
it's crazy like either that or here this
is probably the truth
we're not as popular as we think
i mean maybe maybe our moms are pumping
up the views on these videos
all right tiger
from the 98th time i guess but [ __ ] dude
like
what do you got to do to have him be
like all right
get on the premiere
list or just come to a [ __ ] screening
i'd do the premiere but i'd also just go
to a theater a couple days early and
watch it
long time ago
and i had an eight oh hey banff man hold
that thought long time mark's like oh
sorry hold on hold that thought i had an
agent who said to me
um it was when edgar
um
parted ways with ant-man
um and i was talking to my agent about
something completely unrelated and he's
like oh my god you know marvel's meeting
with everybody this week
to kind of keep ant-man together
and i was like well
not everybody
and he goes uh well yeah i guess you're
right
and i go not that i give a [ __ ] but i
said like in a world where they
apparently are reaching out to everybody
like
you know
why why do you think i'm never anybody
and at the time my agent was just like
oh come on
disney's gonna work with mr stoner guy
and i was like oh all right and i
literally accepted that like i was just
like oh that must be it i don't think
that's it maybe he was just being kind
maybe what he meant to say was like what
disney's gonna work with untalented guy
[Laughter]
regardless over to you bam man i was
just gonna say mark's like if somebody
would just offer us a screening two days
early meanwhile brett deacon's watching
at home like
the [ __ ] let me tell you something brett
deacon and the good people at 40x and
screen x
they are literally doing the lord's work
like the only reason i don't shed a tear
over the fact that we don't get to go to
the premieres of [ __ ] because i'll be
honest with you i don't even want to go
to the premiere like premieres are
you know like let people enjoy that [ __ ]
i just want a screening in advance so i
could start like talking about it or not
talking about it if that's what they
prefer so the good folks at screen x and
40x have not let us down in like two
[ __ ] years the studios which i guess
to be fair
have to approve it
but ultimately i guess we are
getting [ __ ] because we have seen the
last few marvel movies at screenx or 40x
and that had to get approved from
somebody at marvel so perhaps we should
shut our mouths now
i just realized
we are getting what we want
we we are
although it does sort of feel as if
it's a bit like our friend works at the
pizza hut
and so he like gives us the pizza that
he can get us even though it's like i'm
not gonna charge before because we're
not gonna use it the other day so you're
gonna have this [ __ ] pizza and you
fill your trunk with dale pizza you
don't care because still look like a
pizza but it's not like pizza was like
come on in
dine on us
enjoy yourself would you like a pan
[ __ ] pizza we got a pan pizza you can
[ __ ] eat let me tell you something if
anyone's learned anything from my dopey
ass career
it's that you don't ever have to enter
the front door that ain't the only way
in to the mansion man they got many
entries and the back door is just as
good and twice as sexy
so we got in the back door
yes
so now we're at the minute brett
deacon's back door that's the
porn version i like i like that we're
now 45 minutes in and we still haven't
had time
gotta talk about it yeah i know and we
were all talking about like it's gonna
be a short show because jc's gotta go
and we don't have much to talk about
anyway [ __ ] have you guys seen
airline on a e
back in like 2004
i got a hot five minutes on premieres
let me go
um obi-wan
thrilling
thrilling conclusion six episodes that's
all they did right that's it until next
time i i this honestly was i was not
you know looking forward to this when
they announced it i was like oh all
right well i could see how you could do
that you and mcgregor's still alive yeah
go for it
who knew who knew that they were going
to give us
some of the best star wars we've ever
seen now naturally on the net i've seen
a lot of people online or you know
disagree and are like i hated this star
wars uh i've seen people hate on almost
all the disney star wars come through
and
if that's your feeling i ain't trying to
change your mind whatsoever but as
somebody who has liked this [ __ ] since
he was seven years old um and been
through all incarnations of it including
the [ __ ] droids cartoon the star wars
christmas special whatever the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] darth vader ever ready
commercial where
[ __ ] bunny came in the lightsaber
went out like i've been there for it all
kids
and um like
i know it was kind of
quasi-borrowed
from you know rebels and the ahsoka
darth vader lightsaber battle but like
obi-wan kenobi
slashing the mask
and anakin skywalker peeking out
and having that conversation
and rectifying that old ass lie that ben
kenobi told about like oh anakin
skywalker darth vader killed your father
annika skywalker
it came from the mouth of darth vader
himself going i you didn't kill him i
killed him blah blah blah
um that scene was absolutely
wonderful and very cinematic man they
used color to show when his soul was
there and when he was just flat out
darth vader
um when there was still a chance to
reach anakin and when it was gone this
is a show that as we've spoken about
before
had zero compunction about sticking with
you know a [ __ ] the questionable
choice of killing a room full of
children
that was made nearly 20 years ago or
less uh they stuck with it
like and built on it and found a way to
tell a really interesting story with a
character that i completely [ __ ]
enjoyed man i enjoyed the journey i
enjoyed the subplot
of uh riva and i enjoyed where it
eventually
went you know look there's a certain
point where
you know
i was relatively sure that luke
skywalker was going to be safe as was
uncle owen as was amp brew and that's
always going to be the
you know trade-off with a show like this
because they gotta leave all the toys
where they belong
you know so that everything [ __ ]
matches up
but i was satisfied with how they
how they pulled it all together
and
you know seeing
little princess leia strap on boots and
a [ __ ] holster
you know
i'm sorry like i'm not a robot that
[ __ ] destroyed me
like seeing a glimpse
of the future um
yeah man i thought they did such a
[ __ ] wonderful job and we got so much
darth vader and
we got a little bit of anakin
as well
we got great lightsaber fights
we got mustafar we got vader's castle
um i checked a lot of boxes for me and
you know i'm sure [ __ ] i'll be
roasted online for [ __ ] liking [ __ ]
that i like
but i don't know i've always been that
way and i've liked this star wars shirt
since i was seven and
i'll this is some of the best star wars
they've ever made i've easily put this
in top 10
star wars for me easily
top 10 favorite star wars moments across
the entire franchise
um i could find at least
one in here um
you know and that probably would be
their
their fight and conversation
i thought that [ __ ] was deep man i loved
it i loved that they had that moment
and they gave it to hayden christensen
you know and he got to
act through the mask and a ton of makeup
and stuff
but uh and i loved how the voice would
kick in and come out and go and whatnot
um
yeah i was happy with with what they did
and
very happy
that you know
the last line was what it was
you know that's some
nifty piece of fun writing right there
to land on hello there you know [ __ ]
good [ __ ] you know mcgregor
carried this thing insanely well i
thought
um so much so that i'm like do another
season
you know i clenched in episode one when
i was like little leia
oh what the [ __ ] she didn't mention this
guy when she you know call me put the
message in r2d2 now by the time i get to
episode six i'm like go on another
adventure [ __ ]
go on another adventure we never talk
about in star wars
[Laughter]
i don't want to be held to that when
this is the possibility when the
possibility is
you can give me some extended universe
stuff that i enjoy now i know there are
some folks online that are like hey man
there was a bunch of wonderful extended
universe
stuff long before all this and the books
and went on they should be doing that
all i can tell you is this
[ __ ] wait a minute
like in a world where they're doing what
they're doing now and they're like
exhausting all possibilities they are
going to get to the thing you love
and probably butcher it according to
your standards but they'll eventually
get to it and maybe they'll get to the
thing you love and do it the way you
want them
to absolutely do it but they're never
going to stop this star wars [ __ ] it's
going to keep [ __ ] going on and on
so chances are if you don't like this
one
stick around i i you know look i'm
looking at andor the same way i was
looking obi-wan
where i'm like
you know
i'll try it but there ain't much for me
there
especially knowing where [ __ ] goes in
rogue one but
they surprised me the surprise the [ __ ]
out of me with obi-wan could be they
surprised me with andor
um i'm all for this
more star wars storytelling
i think i've spoken about this before
but it reminds me of something that
jason reitman said to me we had him over
here for the podcast one day
and he said the best piece of advice
that his dad
the great ivan reitman rest in peace
rest in power
uh
uh told him
as his dad the filmmaker
uh he said uh i wish i had made more
movies he said problem was i made
ghostbusters and then i kept looking for
the next ghostbusters he's going but
ghostbusters comes along once in a
lifetime
he's like so while i waited all those
years to find what i thought would be as
good as ghostbusters i could have been
making more and more stories and yeah
some of them might have been bad but a
lot of them might have been good at
least i would have had more chances to
have good movies
so he said that was his one big regret
was he didn't make more i kind of look
at star wars like that like just let
them go pick as much as they want some
of it you're going to love some of it
you're going to feel like doesn't meet
the mark
and some of it may just like hit you
dead set in the heart dead straight in
the heart man there were moments in this
show
that absolutely did that for me and
you know
it's
it's different when you're judging a
two-hour movie versus like a show where
you know you get to extend the life of a
story
and i get it some people aren't
satisfied these ain't the movies that
they grew up with
um this is just one person talking as
somebody who did grow up in these movies
i like it i ain't saying you're wrong if
you ain't for you
so be it
but i had a [ __ ] blast watching this
obi-wan kenobi show and that is
something that like if you went back in
time and told me i was gonna say that
it'd be like
why is it pornography
what makes it special a lot made it
special had nothing to do with
pornography oddly enough
uh so i loved it man i thought the last
episode was wonderful and
you know
i
i
i'll revisit that last hour particularly
again the last episode i thought they
did such a great job i hope they do
season two
over to you mr mark bernard
um i i i agree with much of what you
said you know like i i think i put on
the internet that
i was like i actually kind of liked this
finale like if it emotionally it does a
lot of the things you wanted to do like
for me the show lives and dies with you
and mcgregor and it lives and dies with
his relationship
to anakin it lives and dies with his
relationship to responsibility to leia
to himself to the past to the future
it's i mean there's a reason why it's
called obi-wan kenobi and not anything
else but when ewan is on the screen
you know and ewing is getting to do
small things like it's really the big
things that yoon is doing it's always
the small things it's always these
little character moments these little
tiny scenes these little you know
exchanges with another person that
reveals some hidden depth that we hadn't
seen before
and so so yeah the the lightsaber battle
is great i wish that they hadn't done
the star wars thing of intercutting it
with something else that i'm not at all
interested in
because
at least with vader and obi-wan i know
what's going to happen neither these
guys are going to die
but maybe we'll get to some truth maybe
there will be an emotional turn maybe
there will be something
excavated between these two old friends
but with riven luke
there's there's no there's no way
there's any real suspense in that moment
at all
so why are we playing it as such you
know and then why are you cutting away
from the thing that i showed up to the
ship to see
to show me a thing that that that bears
no impact whatsoever
and worse again luke skywalker is now
not the kid who can say i've grown up on
this rocket nothing's ever happened to
me you know except for that time when an
evil jedi hunted me in my house and i
ran into the
sands you don't know about that he just
thinks it was some tuscan raider
activity they had a line to cover that
ship remember he's like the tuscan
raiders going nuts get out of here go
running i guess but once you start
hearing like laser swords
these are really advanced tuscan raiders
man
um i i think that that there's a lot in
the finale that works i think there's
some pieces of it that were in the wrong
place
because to your point the last line of
that show should have been hello there
because that's the first thing that he
says to luke when he sees him in a new
boat like that's how you join those
things i don't actually need him to talk
to qui-gon after that i need you to cut
the credits after that
the qui-gon scene felt like he was in
the wrong place because you have a scene
you have come on spider-man come on
spider-man come on obi-wan i'm buried
under a bunch of stuff and i gotta find
the way to motivate myself to get out of
here and i'm i'm i'm trying i'm trying
and then i connect with luke and lay and
i understand that that's the future
and then qui-gon shows up and tells you
the thing has almost made me cry with
your command spiderman
that's the moment that's exactly what
they're they're they're they're
conjuring with that that boy was so good
in that moment who was spiderman come on
peanut butter man just cracking voice oh
that boy is a perfect [ __ ] spiderman
anyway
all right but like that's that's the
moment where qui-gon should show up
that's what it is so what do you mean so
how do their do your version of come on
spider-man
and
you're doing the version where obi-wan
is under the the rubble he's trying to
hold up the force he's starting to fail
because a mountain is on top of him and
he's his hand is buckling the dust is
coming through and then he flashes in
his eyes and he sees luke and he sees
layer
and then qui-gon shows up and qui-gon
says you're not done yet
like there's still more to do or you
need to forgive him or whatever that is
but that's the next that's that beat and
that's why qui-dan shows up and so you
don't need him with his bad wig later on
showing up in the sand where it means
nothing you need it where it means
everything
and obi-wan is still the hero of that
moment but he needed his mentor to
finally show up and say now you're ready
to be the man you have to be
i may be really big but that was [ __ ]
beautiful man if we were in the bar i'd
be like give it up for mark
clap [ __ ] that would have been great uh
because the story is over when he says
hello there when he's do you want to
meet him yes i do
then with the
god get out
go away
you know i think that that
we probably talked about on the on the
podcast before but it's the moment in
the fugitive this is going to sound like
a non-sequitur but i'm going somewhere
where it's the you know i didn't kill my
wife i don't care right like that famous
exchange with tommy lee jones and
harrison ford
rumor has it that there was like a
three-page scene that they were supposed
to do
and tommy lee jones and house and floyd
were like
what's the scene about the scene's about
i didn't kill my wife and i don't care
so let's just say that and so they
pulled out three pages of script and
that's all you get
because that's what the scene is
and so
riva fails to kill luke skywalker and
obi-wan fails to kill obi-wan and fails
to kill anakin's death
and these two people these two failed
jedi meet each other in the desert and
then they have a two-page scene talking
about their failure when all you needed
was
i couldn't do it
and then everyone says neither could i
and like that's it
i'd be a [ __ ] western just be
evocative just just say the little bit
you need to get that across and like
bounce out
like i feel like it started to labor
things and it's just
and i won't i won't even get into the
weird ass
thing of
i'm in a star destroyer and i got to
chase this blockade runner
that i can't shoot apparently
i can't use a tractor beam which i know
a star destroyer has i can't use a fleet
of tie fighters hanging out in the bay
i'm just gonna plink at this thing with
these
and then and then it's like obi-wan gets
in his little tiny ship
and it's like uh what should we do sir
well we're going after obi-wan really
yes
okay should we should we should we
launch the tie fighters and blow up the
other ship and squash rebellion
no i just want that guy
like questionable strategies and tactics
happening on the bridge of that star
destroyer i'll chalk that up
vader year one instead
i'll also say
and i don't disagree with anything
mark's saying
but this may be the same star destroyer
captain who grows up to be like
oh another escape pod no life forms
let's let it go save the energy
oil is expensive don't shoot that escape
pod in a new hope
like
yeah
you know i just like the engineer to not
be awful at their jobs
this is a side note but how thrilling
was it in this show like this is what i
love about these shows
you know and i know people be like this
is [ __ ] not writing it's fan service
but
seeing a snow speeder
was [ __ ] thrilling
even though we weren't on hoth
seeing a thermal detonator and what it
absolutely does
was [ __ ] thrilling
um the one thing that i'm not thrilled
by i don't bump into it i don't give a
[ __ ] but i'm like why this
is disney star wars is just all about
the rocks floating in the air
to them the force is all about like
literally ryan ryan johnson made a joke
about it where he's like moving rocks
like they're still [ __ ] playing with
rocks bro
when they cover him with rocks i was
like no
not the rocks here it comes and they all
go [ __ ] floating and [ __ ] i'm like oh
it's ray but i guess
no there's no connection between rey and
ben kenobi right that was the idea they
were gonna be but ultimately no
at star wars celebration this past month
they literally sold a box of rocks and
called it the jedi training kit for like
40 bucks
whoa
whoa bro those rocks better have [ __ ]
like
motors in them
the air for 40 bucks
um
and then so i i like the finale aside
from a couple of little odd stylistic
choices what did you think of this what
do you think of owen and beru in action
um
i mean
sure
i guess you know like
either she's gonna be formidable enough
to stay like to be an inquisitor
to be third sister to be one of vader's
hand-picked you know wounded wounded
though severely wounded it's really
wounded but also it is unclear exactly
how wounded a lightsaber blow will make
you because everybody seems to get up
from them when it's convenient except
for but sure
except for quagmire the only person who
never heals from a lightsaber oh my god
i got stabbed
the only guy to get stabbed to death
with a lightsaber
yes
the greatest jedi that ever was um
but like again it's it's
good for you owen like
i guess and i don't quite understand
obi-wan's like oh they're in he's in
good hands with you don't need me to
protect him except for the time when you
pretty much let
one person never game for this kid get
this kid
but you guys are doing a bang-up job
owen and beru you got it from here i'm
gonna go hang out in the desert and
never come back
i'll say uh joel edgarton did a
wonderful job channeling phil brown
like he definitely i felt
you felt
like yeah like i felt like he bridged
that gap between episode three and
episode four real nice
i'd say he played it like a western i
thought that was kind of cool
i never thought of uncle owen as a
[ __ ] you know being in the western
but he's literally a [ __ ] farmer so
of course
yeah it makes sense that he could defend
the ranch so to speak
i also forgot for like a red hot second
that like
when you go into the little igloo
you got that whole weird open
we're in the ground backyard kind of
affair going on
terrace yes just seeing that alone was
kind of fun and
um you know the only thing that was
missing from the big battle with riva
though is if they beru smashed her over
the head with a [ __ ]
jug of blue milk and [ __ ] that knocked
her out that would have i would have
brought things full circle jc would have
been like oh
we're gonna sell so many blue mail
i hope they do it again
yeah i mean i think that what would you
do differently
um i think there's i have a bigger macro
note because the thing that i was i was
surprised by was the show's desire to
end optimistically
right it's like we're ending with you
know obi-wan is a hero and he saved leia
and he saved luke and now he's he's
embraced his destiny and so it's like a
rosy day in in the in the outer rim of
the of the galactic empire
and i mean it's still it never quite
jived from me how that person
after this whole adventure then just
hangs out on tatooine for another nine
years waiting for that kid to grow up
he seems as if
he's
don't come back are you are you calling
him a groomer don't do that mark not a
groomer
but i i and and and this might be an
interpretation thing and i'm sure you
have a feeling about in jc has a feeling
about everybody's feeling about it but
my feeling about when we first meet
obi-wan kenobi
as alec guinness
is that he was a bit in hiding he was a
bit in in isolation he was a little bit
not quite exiled but a self-imposed
exile
you know like he could have re-engaged
with the rest of the rebel alliance if
he wanted to he didn't and it's not as
if he was always watching out for luke
because clearly he wasn't
so what is he doing there and it always
felt a bit like you know there was there
was a certain amount of shame and once
you see revenge and sit once you see
that it's a story to a certain degree
about only one's failure
then okay all right that tracks
and then you but the decision to start
obi-wan
in failure mode kind of engage him a
little bit with the rebellion and then
make him a hero and
it didn't track for me especially when
you have to reckon with the idea
that now obi-wan kenobi
has let this guy live twice
and this guy is about to be responsible
for the deaths of millions of people and
we as an audience are supposed to feel
okay about that
like he's space hitler
he is a hundred percent going to go up
and destroy alderaan he's 100
darth vader darth vader i thought you
were blaming ben kenobi for alderaan i
was like he's a [ __ ] hermit it's not
his fault
trying he got on a spaceship he's trying
you're talking about it i'm talking
about ben kenobi has now twice had the
chance to kill darth vader before he
becomes space hitler and doesn't but he
don't know he's gonna become space
hitler he doesn't but he knows he's a
bad dude especially now especially on on
when he's on the heels of chasing leia
through that town and he's forced
crushing civilians
like the the word has spread of the
deeds of darth vader to the point where
obi-wan is afraid of him at the jump
like he knows that he's not to be
traveling with and he's not just mean
like he's he might be all the way gone
and he lets him live and so
i mean it does add a certain resonance
to i just felt millions of souls crowded
anguish and then silence was like bro
that's on your head
you did that on me
if i remember my star wars correctly
vader does not destroy alder
no but
grand moff tarkin destroys alderaan he
does but vader's standing right there
yeah but he can't give the order and
[ __ ] like that
how [ __ ] up though is it seeing
alderaan
kind of nice though though because
finally it personalizes it it's like oh
oh that's what that was no wonder they
wanted it so people wondered they were
sort of no wonder she was like no it's a
peaceful place never my peaceful place
like when i was a kid peaceful places
all right they live near a lake
these [ __ ] like had a civilization
an entire [ __ ] planet buildings
rocket ships and whatnot they just
[ __ ] blew it out of the sky you know
as weird as watching this show and
you're watching uncle owen and aunt peru
blow to [ __ ] you know just people
using guns and [ __ ] like that
being badasses and then you realize one
day they're just gonna wind up burning
in their house
they die
burning in their house
outside or inside on the in that weird
sunken floor it doesn't clear well
yeah they were probably shot inside and
then brought outside and then set on
fire or they went inside to get outside
and then [ __ ] shot and put on
it so they're outside the igloo that's
where they find the bodies yeah
they're a couple smolders that's how
they wind up their big story
like they're they're heroes of this
episode so to speak but it's like
you know [ __ ] after the credits roll
they could have put up one of those
codas
like these two burned alive one day
yeah
the
after graduating from the farmhouse
academy of tatooine
you know plow the back 40 and eventually
die burning
jc you're [ __ ] deep in the extended
universe and [ __ ] like that did paper do
like anything where luke was like
you know i'm finally gonna take the time
to mourn my aunt and uncle
no
nothing that i ever read
i mean like he really just moved the
[ __ ] on man he's like man and uncle are
dead let's get off this [ __ ] rock
they were holding me back let's go old
man
i think that
i was just gonna just to finish that
initial thought the thing that i might
have changed was i think i would have
started obi-wan kenobi in the ice cube
junior position of
i'm a partner i'm an active part of the
rebel alliance i'm i'm involved in
ferrying these children to safety
like i know that i failed with vader and
i know that order 66 is something on my
head and so i am now i feel responsible
for this
and then he gets pulled away because of
leia and then all of that stuff still
happens but his his his emotional state
is not one of resignation and loss it's
active i'm i'm being i'm being a force
for good and a force for change and then
he comes into contact with vader who
smashes everything this is all part of
vader's plan to bring this man low and
to enter to rob from him everything that
means something to him the same way that
that's what obi-wan did in vader's mind
to vader and so that when you get to the
end of it and you get to the like i
hacked off half of your face and i
forgive you and all that stuff and vader
says now your failure is complete
because now you've lost everything and
you're unwilling to kill me which you
should [ __ ] do because i would kill
me if i were you
and that feeling of i broke this man
like he he he had spirit he had spunk he
was because now i expect him i expect
obi-wan to be like a [ __ ] general of
the rebel alliance again
but now he's going to go off into the
desert sad you know with a little
sparkle of like at least i say with
those two kids
but everything else i was working for is
gone
like i don't know i i optimism was not
the the
tone that i was feeling the show wanted
to to end on
um but they chose it because they wanted
a swelling music theme as he left
the
rumor was there were some rewrites in
the process as well
too lots of rewrites there's like 90
writers involved in all this stuff
because there's two whole different
staffs
who who whacked at it
i was gonna say
i like seeing qui-gon at the end because
it ties it back to
what obi-wan's mission was at the end of
revenge of the sith my problem is
is it was like they were paying quite
our liam neeson by the word like he said
eight words and he was and it was snarky
he was like
we're running we got some time to spend
and then the end
look
if you're obi-wan kenobi in episode one
you spend the entire two hours of that
movie being like qui-gon stop talking
back to the bosses on the council you
should be on the council you should do
this you should do this fall in line
fall in line master fall in line right
and then his master's dying wish is
do the thing that you've been telling me
for two hours we shouldn't be doing
which is train anakin and obi-wan is
like uh okay it's my master's dying wish
i'm gonna do this against my better
judgment which obi-wan then fails
miserably at right anakin turns to the
dark side wipes out all the jedi obi-wan
goes into exile he's been calling on his
master now
since
you would imagine for 10 years since the
end of revenge of the sith and this is
the dialogue that they have together
it's not like
master qui-gon i'm so sorry i failed in
the one
i failed my mission in your dying wish
i it's literally a sarcastic six-word
exchange and then they walk off into the
desert together there should have been
and to mark's point like if qui-gon's
like look your work has just begun
we're going to sit together and i'm
going to show you how to become a blue
force ghost because by the way nobody
else has ever been a blue force ghost
in the history of star wars obi-wan is
literally seeing the first ghost in star
wars and he it's not like a shock to him
it's like he's been talking to old
ghosts
i'm like
this feels weird like obi-wan and qu
like obi-wan should feel something
towards qui-gon other than like
oh my college buddies back like no no
when you last saw that guy he was dying
in your arms and he was like your father
it was weird that really rubbed me the
wrong way
and left the show feeling weird like it
wasn't enough
for me as a fan to just be like look we
got liam neeson to show up on a green
screen from london
like it wasn't enough
um
it needed to mean something and to your
point like yeah but
if he just said you know what obi-wan
you were right
if that was it like shouldn't have
trained him
shouldn't have done it my mistake
that i that i that i faded you to carry
on
like i apologize for the heartbreak
that's on like if if the end of this
show is about forgiveness
you know then like loop that back around
also
um
but yeah it just it it served no purpose
other than look there's liam
which is the wrong reason to have liam
neeson be there
the other thing that drove me nuts and i
saw mark said on his instagram he was
like i give it a six which is about what
i think i'd give kenobi a six out of ten
which is fine
but like the other thing that drove me
nuts is
think about in a new hope
luke who's met ben kenobi for 10 seconds
and got a toy out of him
leia went on a whole mission with him
and when kenobi struck down by vader
leia's like oh it's okay luke
like
[ __ ] this guy saved your life ten
eight years ago
like you're not gonna react to that
now
like that should have been built in
there somehow because she doesn't have
any reaction when he dies
and seemingly she knew him better than
luke did they went on a whole adventure
together that part also i was like yeah
you covered the hologram thing but you
forgot about the fact that
when he dies she's like who's that old
guy
like they had no connection there which
obviously you can't do 43 years later
but 45 years later but to put something
like that in
um
and then
you know everybody's like should they do
a sequel
my thought on a sequel to kenobi the one
that i actually want to see doesn't have
kenobi in it it's a show with ice cube
junior
that runs parallel to rebels
so you get
him starting
his faction of the rebellion alongside
the rebels crew and you can get those
shows to cross over a little bit because
he was my favorite part of the show i
thought i thought he felt the most
like
original trilogy star wars i want to see
more him
i mean the thing that that i kept on
wondering and i think we might have
talked about it is
there was a version of this show that's
incredibly subversive
that decides
not that you're going to kill darth
vader
but that
it creates a branching timeline the same
way that star trek like when they went
to the movies when jj read the movies
it was like you know what you know the
star trek that you know
and then we have a brand new version of
the star trek in which spark and kirk
are not friends and their enemies and
like all of this business that's
happening is not part of the original
candidates are holding it
whereas at the end of kenobi instead of
going back to tatooine and waiting for
luke to eventually mature everyone's
like you know what
i'm going to train the girl instead
you know and then suddenly you're in
this like in glorious bastards world
where we killed hitler and suddenly it's
a whole new [ __ ] world like
find a way to tell me a star wars story
where i don't know the end
and every star wars story for the last
every live-action star wars story for a
good long while i know how it's going to
end but then suddenly in a while in
which what layers of jedi
like and was the was the jedi that
everybody hoped for
like what if he does training or what if
she does go to jacob and to learn from
yoda what if
what if this becomes
you know
her story
i'd be 100 down for some version of that
like no it's not canon at all no it
doesn't slide in with these movies at
all [ __ ] it
like if the story's better give me a
thing i've never seen
um
we'll always have those movies and we'll
always have that canon but then there's
a certain folly in continuing to try to
slot tiny stories in where we know too
much about them
because there can be no surprise
and that's why we came to star wars in
the first place that's why anybody comes
with stories because i want to know how
it ends
and if we know how it ends
then then then there's a certain
fundamental lack of enjoyment and just
seeing how it ends
i don't know that's just me
i just heard some [ __ ] smart words
words with multi-syllables from a guy
who really thought about it kids for me
you get as [ __ ] like it
from mark you get some thoughtful
[ __ ] uh
dissection
of the thing that you love or didn't
like
or gave us dicks a six you guys are
[ __ ] tough
uh give it up for the boys uh mark
bernard and bathman everybody
thank you sir and listen thank you to
everybody who made kenobi like there are
moments that i do love and i think as
we've talked about it before in the
podcast star wars for me is is about the
moments the moments that remind me how
it felt to be eight years old watching
these things for the first time
and if you can get those moments if you
can get me there
done 100 and there's a hund there's
absolutely moments in kenobi there's
there's moments in men there's moments
in every piece of star wars that's ever
been made that make me feel young again
and so i'm here for it um but i think
that there was there there were places
you could have sewed
and stitched things together a little
bit tighter that's all
that's just mean a six is not a failing
grade a six is like a c plus what is
this a c plus what
that's what you got out of it was a c
plus yeah
joints of a trying to get my guy to look
at you what
what
i wish we were in a box next to each
other banff man shouldn't me and mark be
next to each other and you pop up above
us
that way we could be like
here's the story
of a man for noggin yes i mean i could
put you guys next to each other i
thought it was more fun to stagger it
though
it's like being at a wedding where i'm
not sitting next to mark it's so [ __ ]
i don't know how to do that i guess i
would have to look that way
i mean don't do it mid show of course
it's like
is go pick up one of these kids the most
adorable version of kev smith ever the q
poss kit
kev smith available at jsonbob.com
37 bucks
please before the economy collapses we
go to a recession
get yourself one of these he's dressed
in little sneakers what are you waiting
for
um let's talk about ms marvel
yes
um episode three
uh i'm still
100 percent digging on this show
i still think she's incredibly endearing
i love the wedding sequence like it was
just gorgeous and wonderful and fuller
the show's been really
a nice travelogue into a a different
culture yeah
i just like the super heroics and the
teen super heroics it's been like oh
that's great just like remember we had
the dude at the bar last week who was
like i watched the show they had
something in their kitchen i've had in
my kitchen my whole life like i just saw
i felt seen
it was it's been a nice like oh so
that's what it's like number one makes
you go like jesus i think we've been
getting married wrong for
it's years televatory very fun
dance and bust to move and [ __ ]
you know i mean the one thing that that
i was you know i'm not gonna say
dismayed by but i was just a little like
because we meet
the the
head nor lady you know who presents as a
mentor presents as a family member like
a dismembered family who has information
that that that
that ms marvel always wanted
and then she's evil like immediately
evil like in 20 minutes she's bad not as
fast as wanda in doctor strange labrie
goes to see her and he's like hey wanda
and she's like
uh hey man are you here to talk about
[ __ ]
uh america and he's like i didn't say
her name and she's like wow
like that's a fast turn i just rewatched
it i was like boy that was quick
um yeah but it is a it's a heel turn a
pretty quick heel turn
yeah so i just wish there was a little
bit more runway that she had
to actually feel that woman's like her
plight and her desire and the fact that
she's been isolated and like just just a
midpoint of
you know she has a legitimate want and
need that kamala can help her with and
comments refusing to do it and so
suddenly it's oh we just got to kill
that girl like that that happens real
fast what is the band connected to you
think
um
you know another
i've i mean it seems that according to
the story that they were telling that
there is a there's a partner band to
that
um
i had a friend theorize that the it's
connected to the negative zone
and then this is this is the beginning
of the introduction
to the fantastic four
are you
serious
so what would the idea they've been
trapped there for a while
yeah that they were i mean dimension
hopping whatever whatever's but like
they were the bad guys like in and i
think it's you know very early if not
the first
fantastic four story
they get stuck in the negative zone when
they go up in the ship and the ship gets
you know hit by you know bombarded by
graves like cognitive rays they end up
in the negative zone they have to steal
the cosmic control rod
from
what's his name again
um
oh man why can't i remember the name of
the big alien bug dude calls the
annihilus
um an ios who has a cosmic control rod
that can open the the portal back to
earth and then you know annihilus would
become along with galactus and doom one
of the kind of classic fantastic four
villains so if these guys are in the
negative zone
and they are members of the annihilus
wave who got lost
and the idea is that we got to open the
negative zone to for them to be able to
get home or worse to invite the
annihilus wave back into earth
then there there is a connection if
that's what that parallel dimension is
and that's what these bands are
to begin the very subtle introduction of
the fantastic four
horn that's six horns up man
all the horns that's nothing but metal
um
it's it's such a well-directed show i'll
tell you what
like the older i get the more i'm like
oh the critic is all right i'm not good
at this job because you look at a show
like that and you're like stunning it's
just visually
[ __ ] stunning
um
good times you know it's another good
[ __ ] looking show i mean are we done
with ms marvel i i have a little more to
say joe
no no i i have little more to say
meaning like i'm done i just i dig the
show i'm here for the road worth
watching continues to be a fun watch
yeah i mean it does suffer because
there's people talking about the
viewership and it is the lowest rated of
all of the the marvel does it continue
to be that lowest rated show um i think
it will at some point you know over time
just begin to grind up more numbers as
people discover it and as it does
continue and connect with other stories
in the mcu problem but this is a brand
new character we've never had that
before on an mcu show everything had
been spun out from the movies
um
until now and so
there's there is a bit of a learning
curve and an audience who doesn't know
what to expect and so didn't just run to
it unlike the way they ran to loki or
falcon winter soldier or one division or
how did how did obi-wan do obi-wan's
done very well and i think the finale
was if not the highest watched
disney plus show ever and the very least
the highest the the the highest the most
watched he can plus you have to last
like a year i think
i'll also say i haven't watched miss
marvel yet but it debuted against kenobi
yeah so do you have a curiosity for the
stupid in the audience like myself
obviously look at my head gear
why would that necessarily affect the
same channel you just watch one and then
watch the other because you're promoting
like i didn't see any promotion for ms
marvel ever it felt like they put
everything behind kenobi
and then ms marvel kind of like
snuck in behind it and was just
drowned by its shadow versus every other
show on disney plus has gotten has
launched
solo like no no other show if you have
to watch one show this is the only one
launching this week whereas these like
ms marvel launched against like kenobi
episode five or four or something
yeah so when you go to disney plus and
the top tile is ultimately there this is
the thing you should watch
it couldn't always be his marvel in fact
it was probably always going to be
canoeing
um still a wonderful show and i'm sure
people will catch up with it now that
kenobi's done
they got nothing but time
um all right we're done with miss marvel
have you watched real quick before we go
into the boys and we'll finish up with
the boys let everybody go home
have you watched um
the old man with jeff bridges um the
first episode i've watched i haven't
watched any more yet
worth watching wonderful
yeah it it reminded me very much of do
you remember the uh the wild sermons
wild storm comic written by warren ellis
and uh kali hender was the artist red
that eventually became the brothers with
the movie with bruce willis yeah um
and the comic book was very serious like
the the movie became a comedy it became
like this this sort of like not quite
buddy comedy because it wasn't so much a
buddy thing but it was like zmakovic is
a crazy assassin and there's morgan
freeman and there's helen mirren and
there's like a bunch of old people doing
cool action [ __ ]
the book was very grim and very gritty
and this reminds me of that in as much
as it's about you know a
old retired
operative who gets called back into
action
very much against his will um and then
what happens when you poke a bear who
has nothing left to lose
um
and it's [ __ ] jeff bridges you know
doing [ __ ] television jeff bridge is
in great [ __ ] shape yeah
like could kick my ass
your ass kicks a guy's ass kicks a lot
of ass in the show it's uh
unexpected and uh you know i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say it's the new reacher
but it's reacher adjacent it's reach
around if you will
it still annoys me that there's no app
to show for a reacher called the reach
around
[Laughter]
the table talking about reach it's the
reach around jeff bridges leaves a body
count though not his eyes reach her but
she [ __ ] leaves the body count it's
worth watching kids if you haven't seen
the old man yet it's on hulu i think
yeah fx and hulu effects in there that's
right it's an fx show
um okay
uh let's finish up with the boys which i
finally watched all the episodes of this
new season i love this show i think
kripke is
[ __ ] a genius man and i think he's
killing it with the show it's just
wonderful um
the uh the storyline this year has been
uh
uh
grippin
um
naturally a lot of people seem to be
waiting for this most current episode
uh the hero
gasm episode uh i thought it was wild i
didn't think it was as wild though as
the [ __ ] you know ant-man dude
walking through the dude's dick hole
holy [ __ ]
that was the thing that i i never even
thought would be possible to see on
television nor did anybody go for it and
i was thoroughly delighted and repulsed
it was it was absolutely wonderful and
i'm sitting there going like well you
know you're always thinking as a writer
so you're like
oh i want to be inside you or i want you
inside of me it's he's going to go up
his ass they went for the [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
and then built a [ __ ] for that guy
to walk through and touch the walls
then they let him sneeze in that dick
hole
and blow the guy apart like just
so [ __ ] out there
is so [ __ ] like wonderful well i just
in the it's watching it at two in the
morning smoking going like why do i try
anymore
who's gonna do who's gonna do something
better than that this year on television
seriously herogasm was utterly fine
but [ __ ] the dude in the [ __ ]
which should have been the [ __ ] title
of the episode
deserves an emmy
um
balls
of the universe on that [ __ ] gag it
was [ __ ] nuts man
absolutely nuts
that was episode four the episode i
think right before or something like
that no i was episode one the show the
season started with [ __ ] that was in
episode one
that was a cold open for episode one
no i can't know i thought that was like
later on for some reason but no
regardless that to me was like jesus
this is nuts uh you know the orgy
everyone kept like hyping here orgasm
but it was like
and i saw real sex when it was on hbo
man there was there was weirder [ __ ] on
that and in terms of like what they've
shown on that show alone
it wasn't like
like through the roof like you know
getting hit with a big water come from
the closet
i i nothing will touch that [ __ ] i
mean pun intended
uh
this
that's like the whale moment that's like
when they drove through the whale
yeah like i think that would have landed
much better if they hadn't like rallied
the entire marketing campaign around it
yeah i agreed you know like it was just
a thing that happened like oh [ __ ] this
is what's happening
huh
yeah
they did lean into the herogasm of it
all yeah like it didn't have the same
you know i think everybody is in in some
fashion always chasing their version of
the red wedding the thing that the
people who read the books know about
that the normies are eventually going to
encounter that's going to be the thing
that pivots the show on itself and
like this wasn't it and didn't have to
be it because what it actually was the
moment that's great is [ __ ] soulja
boy and butcher trying to beat down
[ __ ] homeland that's the thing like
you call you know the the episode
everyone's like here orgasm but it's
like [ __ ] that this is the episode where
like homelander and soldier would go
toe-to-toe and then [ __ ] butcher
jumps in and it becomes a three-way
[ __ ] fight
to a standstill essentially where he
gets chased off what's that dude's name
that actor
um who plays which one homelander
anthony starr
deserves an emmy nomination at least
if not a [ __ ] win like
an incredible performance
not just like oh you hate you love to
hate him like j.r ewing but he's [ __ ]
terrifying
that's the thing and it's and it's so
quick
and it's it's like all in the eyes it's
all in the lips it's all it's all very
finely tuned like muscle work in his
face of just how to get that guy from
being a poster boy to a serial killer
and it just just like that he shifts
and the [ __ ] like the gollum scene
where he gets to talk to himself in the
mirror is like come on tiger like you
know like you know what it's all about
you know you just gotta let me in let me
let me let me take control buddy i think
we've got this
don't be a [ __ ] yeah man
it's
it continues to be a a really cool show
very twisty tourney
um huey's wonderful
starlight's wonderful those you know
she
huey gets to be funny uh she's you know
they she they make her the spine
oftentimes yeah
but she had a few really wonderful
moments like funny moments recently
yeah like this this episode was actually
a one in which lots of things in the in
this season
pivoted around like it's and again
spoilers boys and girls we haven't seen
it yet but huey and starlight break up
you know it's the big climax or the
first big climax i'm assuming between
homelander and soulja boy and
and butcher
you know mother's milk like he reveals
the reasons why he's got issues about
soldier boy you know like all of these
things that are happening and you know
starlight is pushed to the edge
by uh by the government lady the the
head popper like
lots of things in this episode you know
pivoted and changed and status closed
began to evolve
to the point where the the hero orgy
was the least interesting part of it
honestly but like
maybe a train dying so he could kill the
dude who paralyzed his brother
like
dragging him dragging him to death yes
yeah like i just there's there's so much
of that show that i love and there's so
many things and i i it never ceases to
amaze me
very much like watching um you know
drunk passengers try to get on a plane
yeah is finding you know people
discovering that the show has actually
always been a very trenchant
right-wing satire
and that homeland there is very much on
that end of the spectrum
kripke uh gets to reunite with what's
his name jensen echols is that yeah
from uh soldier boy supernatural yeah
the supernatural kids man uh because
that that's where kripke believes he's
created that show didn't he
he's i've interviewed him he's great
[ __ ] um carl i've interviewed him he
was great uh
um who plays huey is his name jack
he's great like
great cast he's very much like
you know the more i see him the more it
becomes like oh yeah no i see the dennis
in you like i see the meg in you like
it's he's kind of the perfect blend of
his parents he was really great in that
show vinyl
like they only did one season on hbo
but you're absolutely right like
it continues to give you something per
episode we're like never saw that before
yeah that's [ __ ] phenomenal like in
episode i don't know if it was one or
two where
um the the congresswoman
like [ __ ] has to like try to [ __ ]
kill the dude in the alley and you get
the idea that's only if she could lay
eyes on him and stuff and lay eyes on
the part of the body
and her like face off scene with
starlight in this recent episode where
she's just like oh i thought maybe he
thought i was trying to crush his head
and her eyes light up and she's like you
know don't you'd lose
really great [ __ ] man well how many of
you have liked
the little nose bleeding
so [ __ ] cool
how many episodes this season
i'm not sure i'm not sure i think it's i
hope it's 10 but i don't know what the
order is
i hope it's more there's one more
it's [ __ ] good [ __ ] man
good [ __ ] um
all right so yes the boys kids it's on
amazon right now you can watch the first
five episodes i think maybe six
yeah i think it's five five uh together
and continues to be some of the best
[ __ ] tv on tv that's not tv because
it's amazing and and you're 100 right
anthony starr is doing any level work
absolutely and it's
also great enemy to those writers man
like giving them like
i i'm telling you right up there with
the um
the prime minister
[ __ ] a pig on live television in that
episode of black mirror
this [ __ ] ant-man walking through a
guy's dick hole is like
you know the bar's just been raised kids
nothing else is going to be the same
after that it's like no yeah
how do you how do you keep them down on
the farm once they've been inside a
guy's dick hole
that was nuts
oh your reaper sweet urethra
i doff my cappathy
um all right kids there it is we just
wanted to review some [ __ ] for jc we
gotta let jc go to bed so we can get on
a plane he's leaving on that jet plane
so he can catch four other jet planes to
get wherever the [ __ ] he's going no
kidding and i think that while while
we're all absent um we will drop into
the feed the episode of uh black man
beyond that i did at the northern fan
con
with uh the wonderful uh ross marquand
from um oh [ __ ] uh he does voices and
stuff he does a ton of voices
he was um
he was a red skull in income infinity
war
but uh but super fun guy had a lot of
great stories and
did some fun voices so yeah
um that'll pop in probably over the
weekend maybe you'll be able to watch
that [ __ ] night man the uh don't
forget kids this weekend if you're in
the colorado area
it's uh fan expo denver i'm going to be
there with jay
taking pictures doing jay and sam bob
get old taking pictures with brian
o'haller and jeff anderson trevor furman
clerks from clerks
and then the week after that is the
fan expo chicago what about you you
going on the road i am not my friend i'm
sticking pretty close to home
until con comic con is my next uh my
next voyage into the into the
hinterlands that's i think like the week
after two weeks after that you could see
me and mark
at comic-con at the movies pop-up at uh
tin roof san diego uh our thursday night
show sold out but we're gonna be
streaming
live updates just about that day's
activity all the news that drops and
stuff friday
mark's gonna be sitting in the eisner
awards dressed up getting ready to [ __ ]
go up there except 10.
we'll see about that
um
but yeah and i'll be you know i've got a
couple panels that i'm on that i can
talk about once they release a schedule
and i'll be doing signings for adora in
the distance at the comixology booth i
think friday saturday and sunday during
the con you know all those details will
come out for sure within the next month
so if you want to go to the movies
pop-up kids uh to want to eat food or
watch shows and eat food and get
[ __ ] drunk but not so drunk they
don't let you on a [ __ ] airplane
uh go to moviespopup.com
for for tickets or go to csmodd.com for
tickets um we'll get you covered and
stuff uh
thursday and friday
i think are sold out but i think we're
trying to cram in some more spots
because
they went fast but this is happening
soon man what are the what's the san
diego dates yeah i think it starts july
21st is the first official day of the
con preview night the 20th the 21st is
day one and that's when we're doing our
fat man and i know they did that you
know november version of the com this is
the first july version of the con since
the pandemic right since 2019 yeah
so it's gonna be a good time but yeah it
won't stream in so you'll be able to
catch us
uh on the stream speaking of
catch look at that little elf catch this
kids look at that don't you want the
cutest slash creepiest slash biggest odd
version of jeff smith he's looking right
he's giving you side eyes like what
what the [ __ ] did you say to me
the eyes keep following me
that's right he's kind of like a jesus
painting man
q basket kevin smith at jnsilenbob.com
37 bucks you could have this [ __ ] bad
boy
in your house
and then every my dream is that when we
do the show everybody has theirs sitting
right here
wow
i mean look dude if they if they're
willing to to patronize our sponsors
[ __ ] help me out by look i bought too
many of these we have a garage filled
with these yeah i'm [ __ ] i don't want
to die with these
take a few off my hands man otherwise
they wind in a wind up in a landfill
help me out 37 bucks i would i would
like the version of this when you're
selling them out of your trunk
don't get me wrong it's san diego
outside that movie's pop-up don't be
surprised you see my hatchback open and
i'm [ __ ]
at that point probably 18 bucks
a smitty i got a smitty right here yes
come on don't you cute he moves look at
the fun you could have with him
um
yeah folks there it is uh we gotta thank
old banff man for letting us do a show
before it gets out of here say a
pre-vacation goodbye banff man
goodbye
well done
i guess uh
i'll see you guys in san diego
that's the next time that's the next
time we're doing a show right i think so
we could probably try a virtual one
before
yeah
yeah we could do a virtual one before
i love virtual shows i don't wear pants
i'm dick out right now
i'm winning to poo in it right here flat
out donald duck below the deck
yeah that'd be nice we get one if we get
one going before san diego and [ __ ] just
because i'm sure there'll be some hype
coming up for uh folks who are
interested in the clerk's three trailer
well let me tell you i'm not saying when
it's gonna drop but i am going to say
pay close attention to my
social media starting on wednesday
for reasons
oh yes um so much to tell you and we'll
be able to tell you hopefully in that
show that streaming show
that jc was talking about man so just
like [ __ ] uncle floyd used to end his
show
with the hugo puppet dancing across the
screen
mark's gonna play the piano and [ __ ]
kev puppets
uh have you had a good time kids if you
had a good time that's because uh the
smart guy says
smart [ __ ]
about that obi-wan kenobi show man and
other shows uh give it up for the brains
of this here operation man marvelous
mark bernardin everybody
thank you sir and that
my friends
is fat man beyond for this evening tune
in next time
same fat time same
fat channels
modcast.com or
a woman's body is her own [ __ ]
business
jeff's kiss everybody except for scotus
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith